everyone knows who won but not everyone
knows how we have not to ask the biggest
question in a generation in out we need
a leader we need to understand who our
voters are appeal to their hearts
people are feeling angry ignored is an
immigration you could be honest is it
race which countries don't you like new
people come in we have squeezed them we
want to turn to a time when we knew our
place when things make sense fictional
or not how to change the course of
history
you have to Huck the political system
package I'm talking about altering the
matrix of politics the social media
platforms are designed to find
like-minded people our software will
locate and target people that no
campaign is ever targetable for people
who don't and have never voted three
million extra votes that the other side
have no idea exists
this is resurgence against the
establishment way to build something
that will be stuck the odds in our favor
what are your expectations realistically
to create the biggest blue glove since
it's the fall of the Berlin Wall very
large yes
let's take you are feeding a toxic
culture to fear and hate
you can't close the box once it's been
opened it's your edge when you found
there is a new politics in tunnel one
that you can't control
[Music]
you